ah there she is meet baby SD Maxine
Stevens John Legend and Chrissy Teigen
revealed their daughter and her name to
the world it's just different it's
beautiful Chrissy shared a glimpse of SC
her and John's third child together with
this adorable photo on Instagram
Thursday check out Mouse holding his
little sister as Luna lovingly looks
down at Baby at Sea are they prepared
are they prepare to be big big siblings
Luna really is she's so nurturing and so
loving and so
she's just very very excited miles is a
little more on the fence because Luna's
always going to be the big girl right
but miles is you know not going to be
the baby anymore so I think he we spend
a lot more time like with him and
telling him that he's always going to be
our baby boy and he's like you know he's
that's it for us so I mean he's gonna be
the best Chrissy captioned the photo
quote she's here SD Maxine Stevens the
house is bustling and our family could
not be happier sharing that John sheds
quote nightly tears of joy seeing
six-year-old Luna and four-year-old
Mouse full of love she also keeps it
real by admitting she's learned you
still need diapers with a C-section
surprised me a lot she ends her caption
writing quote we are in Bliss thank you
for all the love and well wishes we feel
it all giving so much to our children
and seeing them embrace it and grow from
how much love and kisses and tension and
affection they get it can be so amazing
Essie was born January 13th John
announced the happy news that evening
during a private concert she's a rainbow
baby for the family following the
devastating pregnancy loss of Chrissy's
son jack in 2020. Chrissy announced she
was expecting again in August of last
year in a wrote in part quote I don't
think I'll ever walk out of an
appointment with more excitement than
nerves but so far everything is perfect
and beautiful well now that Estes here
the family is a party of five and having
a growing family is something Chrissy's
spoken out about in the past I
definitely want a big family I want um
I could use a few boys to counter this
weird girl love of John that's happening
right now
but um yeah definitely I think I I mean
we'll go four or five however long
and I just don't feel like anybody
regrets having too many kids
congrats to the beautiful family
[Music]